لا تتعلق سيارة رولز رويس أبدًا بالإثارة ،
فهذه ليست سيارة تقودها عندما تريد
قلبك أن ينبض بشكل أسرع ،
فهذه
منطقة رضاء تبلغ ثلث مليون دولار
خارج وداخل شبح رولز رويس
ستلاحظ ذلك  من البساطة التي
ترتبط عادةً بالتصميم الاسكندنافي ،
أعتقد أن فولفو رولز رويس السويدية تحدثت
إلى عملائه وتعلموا أنهم لم
يعودوا يريدون
رمزًا للتخزين المؤقت للثراء
ولكن لا يزال هناك القليل من الوميض
بالطبع
يقود سيارة رولز رويس  تجربة فريدة حقًا
إذا أخبرتك أنها ناعمة جدًا ، فأنت
لا تشعر بالطريق كثيرًا ،
وستحصل على فكرة أنه مثل قيادة
كاديلاك قديمة وهي تتخبط ،
فهي ليست سيارة رولز رويس تشعر بقدر كبير
من التحكم في
الواقع ، إنها تشعر بالدقة مع
التوجيه الذي أشعر به تمامًا
ولكن في نفس الوقت لا أشعر
أنني منزعج من التفاصيل الدقيقة
لسطح الطريق ، فالشبح هو
سيارة السيدان الأصغر حجمًا من رولز رويس والأكثر ملاءمة للسائق ،
فهي تمتزج في bette  r على الطريق أكثر من
الشبح الأكبر الذي تتمتع به رولز رويس ،
ولكن على ارتفاع 18 قدمًا ، لا يزال الأمر رائعًا ،
ما هو لطيف حقًا هو هذا ناقل الحركة الفائق السلاسة
الذي بالكاد تشعر بأي تغيير في التروس
والشيء الجميل في امتلاك هذا المحرك الكبير v12
ليس القوة الخام الكبيرة  على الرغم من
أن هذا أمر رائع ،
إلا أن السيارة لا تشعر
أبدًا أنها يجب أن تعمل بجد
حتى عندما تغلق على
الطريق السريع من 0 إلى 60 بأسرع ما يمكن أن
تكتشف الكاميرات التغييرات السطحية
والعيوب على الطريق أمامك ،
لذا فإن التعليق  يمكن أن تكون مستعدًا
للرد عليها ، حيث يستخدم ناقل الحركة الأوتوماتيكي
نظام تحديد المواقع العالمي (GPS) وبيانات الخرائط
لتحديد التروس المناسبة مسبقًا
للتلال القادمة ومهندسي المنحنيات الذين
يقضون الكثير من الوقت في التفكير
في الصوت في هذه السيارة ،
إنه ليس نوعًا من الصمت المطلق يشبه القبر.
لقد دفعت إلى الاعتقاد
ولكن الضوضاء تمت تصفيتها على الأرجح
أن الشيء الوحيد الذي أود تغييره في
الشبح هو المكابح التي أتمنى أن
يشعروا بها بشكل أفضل قليلاً
أنهم يقومون بعمل جيد لإيقاف سي  ar
لكنهم لا يتواصلون مع الطريق ، على
سبيل المثال ،
لا أشعر بأنني أشعر بمعرفة
أين سأوقف هذه السيارة بالضبط بمجرد
الضغط على الفرامل
للشخص الذي يشتري رولز رويس
جوست هذا ليس  لن تكون السيارة الوحيدة
التي يمتلكونها ، فمن المحتمل أن تكون لديهم سيارات
فيراري ربما لامبورجيني ،
لكن هذه ستكون السيارة التي يركبونها
عندما يريدون خفض ضغط الدم لديهم